salut les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux il y à un peu moins de deux ans
je publiais ma première vidéo sur
youtube c'était pendant le premier
conflit
aujourd'hui est la barre du million a
été franchie vous êtes plus d'un million
à me suivre ce succès c'est le vôtre
alors à millions de fois merci pour
votre curiosité votre soutien et vos
commentaires il me donne toute l'énergie
qu'il faut pour vous proposer toujours
plus de vidéos alors pour fêter ce
million et bien je vous prépare une
belle surprise quelque chose que je n'ai
pas l'habitude de faire ça arrive très
bientôt alors restez connectés
d'ici là n'oubliez pas le savoir ça se
partage